here's just the sad clip this really
this really is sad because we've
speculated that the former president you
know the former guy
really
doesn't have normal relationships with
people and that includes his own kids
here is
just another one of these little
segments and it it really is sad
eric trump was speaking at this reawaken
america tour and remember eric trump is
not generally known as the smart one
and uh the reawaken america tour is this
kind of like
anti-covet-denying anti-vaxx
religious revival type tour that goes
around the country it's the one where
that so-called comedian jim brewer did
his cockatoo impression that had so many
of the people in the audience and
hysterics
that i didn't find very funny but so
eric trump spoke at one recently and he
did the really cool thing you know
showing the alpha nature of everything
he called his dad trump and he said that
you know he really loves him and trump
said have a good
have a good weekend
um
do you guys feel bad for eric trump but
really for all of trump's kids take a
look
you know what dad there is so much love
in this room for this country and for
you and everything that you accomplished
and um
i speak on behalf of every single person
here they love you i love you we're
proud of you and uh just hold your
breath everybody hold your breath
well thank you very much and everybody
enjoy yourselves and have a good weekend
i'll be in ohio soon i'll see you all oh
my god oh my god i mean it's just so
awkward if you've been around truly
narcissistic people
um
this is typical of them and this is
typical of how they behave
but as as far as like a parent parenting
thing is concerned you know your kid
says i love you
and you go well thank you very much and
have a nice weekend
it's sad and uh imagine that that's the
one phone call eric's allowed right i
mean we don't know how often eric's
allowed to talk to his dad um it really
gives me kind of like please love me
daddy's sort of vibes and it is sad it
really is sad it doesn't seem as though
trump has a normal relationship with his
kids and it's all very strange but it is
what it is and there's really not too
much more that we can say about it